so so yes so this course is the coffee
it is discussions and and in order for
the course to be successful we have to
be able to discuss very delicate
personal issues in a very safe way and
to be honest it cannot be that's been so
afraid to reveal the positions and
various topics including race language
identity and and and one way to do it is
to given that I had a baby at the very
beginning of the course I had the
questionnaires about where they came
from I mean which is they spoke where
they grew up I was able to to use that
to trigger discussions you know so if we
read it talks about authenticity for
example if an African can you be an
authentic writer if you write in English
then I knew that some of the students
I'll get to this issue for example where
they stood at who although she was black
and Hispanic but she wasn't very fluent
in Spanish and and she wasn't clear
whether her not being fluent in Spanish
neither any less Hispanic you see so I
could I was able to use that in order to
trigger a discussion around this notion
that we had read in this famous debate
between Chinua Achebe and googy what
jungle about African writers can an
African can you write to be
authentically African if they write in
English or French for that matter so
that that was one way to trigger rich
discussion by taking a text that
connected to these issues and making it
personal so the motive there was rich
discussions are best arrived at if there
is claim from a personal basis where
students are invested in trying to find
an answer that can work for them in the
in the personal lives or in the lives of
the families the community is the
country is etcetera so that was the one
key technique and then there wasn't a
condition for it twelve days the
discussion is to have mutual respect and
and and Trust because in these questions
they cannot be
right and wrong and one answer so it's
based on your own level of comfort what
you know cheston's you've made for your
personal life or your identity and and
we'll have to be able to accept
different opinions but sometimes that
was not easy because they were like in
the class another student who spoke
Spanish fluently and move um self as
Hispanic and it was another student
wouldn't speak Spanish so frankly who
also view SF as Hispanic so right there
there was a potential for for was more
Hispanic you see but yet they're both is
panic in their own ways you see and this
is where the debate get very interesting
you know how how do you define being
Hispanic and and and then we'll back to
that very core question who belong who
doesn't belong and this is where again
language and identity become tools for
either inclusion exclusion and since the
course is eventually about inclusion
that how can we use these different
entities to create the space where one
can have some that's much dozen in the
parts